somebody once said that the chains of  habit  are too light to be felt until they're  too heavy to be broken  i had been terrified of public speaking  i couldn't do it i'd throw up  and i knew if i didn't cure it then  i never cured it  and so i saw an ad in the paper for the  dale carnegie course  which worked on developing your ability  to speak in public  and i went down there  be  a good smile has the same effect as a  puppy's tail on a puppy they made us all  these crazy things to get out of  ourselves and so we stood on tables and  did all kinds of things  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  if i hadn't have done that  my whole life would have been different